and you want you go out with your friends and
he goes out with his friends with you they go out
together it's a marriage
you have to
look for so much conflict to talk about
it you have to find a solution
time part 40 soak up a separation
if that's the problem because  The thing like
me tells me that I always have problems
and
this is going to bother me more than yesterday
in another apartment.
Problems
she
wanted
as well as
that she always wants another but
from them but that it is not hit they are not
flying to hit the marriage  It is a
commitment so the commitment is not
yours alone nor hers alone it is both of us
neither of us was sorry
neither of us wanted to
contribute that little grain of
sand so that things could
change and you or a member and you
great
I gave it to you  your advice and I'm leaving
[Music]
until I arrive
if you want the marriage to fall
apart you are responsible
never look for anyone
seeing that they none of you  s two I
was willing to make a sacrifice
so I stood up from the table apparently there
was nothing else to do
then
outs
I turned nothing
I
keep fading
[Music]